hello my name is ed barrett and i direct
the william corbett poetry series at mit
sponsored by the comparative media
studies and writing program at mit
and tonight we are here to happily
celebrate a new anthology of poems by
six current and former mit women
students entitled our ancestors did not
breathe this air
our guest host for this evening is in
john
amirthanayagam
in john is a multilingual poet
essayist translator
author of over 20 books of poetry and
editor of the beltway poetry quarterly
indran worked with the six poets you
will hear tonight as they put together
the anthology of their poems
which we're very very happily
celebrating
in john welcome and i will now turn the
screen and the evening over to you and
the readers
thank you so much
what an honor and a pleasure it is
tonight and a thrill um to introduce
these poets uh you know this is a
a much loved book uh and it's about to
appear
um it's a first book
you know this evening is the first on
many levels i mean the first time these
poets
from mit will read together
on literally a world stage through this
zoom platform
it's the first time that beltway
editions will publish a book poems our
first book so we're thrilled uh
sarah k hill baron and i the
co-publishers of beltway
it's the first time
also that i have the pleasure to present
really some of my favorite
new poets in america and
and as a migrant also to these to this
country
thrilled also again
to celebrate this welcome addition
to the poetry of migration um
i wrote this small poem
some weeks ago
uh when the the durhami for the book
arrived
it's called to the poets of our
ancestors
did not breed this air
from their publisher
this pivot into publishing
is pure pleasure pirouette
satisfaction limitless and roaring in
the book fair marketplace going head to
heel against the marketing team of the
behemoth as we the small press beltway
editions arm ourselves with a potent
book of charged lyric poetry written by
six young women who believe still in
honor and truth while we snort and snarl
and believe too
as if for the first time in verses that
will make all the difference
in lives of men and women not only at
funerals
not only during moments of melodically
before the mountain of debt
of uncertain resolutions
that just shift the mountain with breath
felicitous melody
listen to the chanting
listen to the charming committed voices
of these youth
they wake up hope
they unleash the song in waves and waves
and this show this air will never again
be ignorant of their breath
blowing here now
infusing the lines these united
states
um
welcome
welcome to this very special evening
um
there are six points
which is a lucky number multiplication
of three
and the first
we will read tonight
uh
very special
uh role she has played in this book not
only writing her poems and contributing
to the dialogue with all the others but
also contributing some amazing designs
which you will see
when you get the book
afifa kazi side
was born and raised
in the dfw that's dallas fort worth
metroplex but is always called two
places home
the suburbs of texas and her
grandparents home
in southern india
after studying biological engineering
with a minor and urban studies at mit
the fifa finds herself for the new
journey as a first year medical student
at ut southwestern
she attributes her love for writing and
storytelling to her grandparents bedtime
stories and the many writing mentors she
has found throughout her life from high
school english teachers to other
immigrant writers
a fifa views poetry as a deeply personal
exchange
of experiences and stories
please go ahead and fifa
welcome
thank you so much for that introduction
to indron it's been such an honor for
all of us to be working with you and
sarah and also just writing in the same
era and space as you so it's really our
honor i have two poems uh for you all
today and i'll go right in so the first
one is called parachute
every time i settle at your feet with a
bowl of coconut oil enhanced whirled and
warmed for exactly 15 seconds in the
microwave
i feel generations
the hands of each and every one of them
must have also moved like yours working
through knots of carelessness and
exhaustion
their wrinkles on your fingers must have
been passed down through hidden battles
i will never know of and this massage
routine must have grown in perfection
through centuries of amis and nani's and
daddy's
when you neatly fold my hair into your
signature braid something tells me these
words have been said before
when will you start taking care of
yourself
i answer by asking you the same
so for this poem something that's really
common in indian cultural or south asian
culture is hair oil massages one is
really good for your hair health but
it's also just a way for mothers and
daughters and sisters to come together
let their hair loose and you know just
pamper each other
and really focus on each other's company
and so really this poem is a no to that
tradition and to my mother and my
grandmothers and the mothers that came
before that
i will now read my second poem titled
dear kashmir
you and i we are not that different
the color of our skin traverses across
the same paint palette at home depot
october sky to dark camel and every
shade that falls in between
you wake up to the warmth of sunshine i
wake up to the warmth of sunshine but
yours fights through the kunlun
mountains and mine through the boston
skyline we both know the smell of the
air just before it's about to snow
but you know other smells too
of sweaty crowds chanting in the streets
of mortal shells dissolving to thin air
a flesh losing its meaning beyond this
nationless land
in the moments before i go to sleep at
night the breeze of my ceiling fan
reminds me of my on the grandmother
and the coolness of her morning terrace
somewhere in the middle of the night it
hits me that i have such fond memories
of a place that takes away yours
it leaves me with nightmares of patterns
of electric fences striped borders so
held up on the you and i they forget
azadi is what keeps us alive i am
suspended in the paradox of my homeland
the sun sends to you its warmth from
92.96 million miles away
we have forgotten to do the same from a
stone's throw away
and so that poem is really an ode to the
kashmiri people who
culture and tradition
and entity is often shadowed by the
ongoing conflict for the region between
india and china and pakistan um and so
it's just really recentering that
kashmiri identity
that's all i have thank you
thank you thank you so much
it is good i know that
to know
the conflicts that are taking place on
the planet you know not only
uh i mean all over and uh we need to
know
and remind it
of the things that we have to
to work on and correct
shabir
was born in queens new york
and has lived in new york ever since
as a pakistani u.s american
she cherishes connecting with a
multitude of cultures
in addition to her own roots
many years after the minor poetry lesson
she had taken in elementary school
alina found a community with these
fellow poets who have taught her how to
express herself creatively and
comfortably
she is forever grateful for them in
their care
having studied data science and
operations research in different fields
of applied mathematics
lena hopes to one day work in policy
development with a quantitative
background
melina usually enjoys reading anything
to do with nature travelling and
pursuing adrenaline inducing experiences
and i would add in writing marvelous
poems go ahead earlier
thank you very much endron and thank you
very much fifa for reading your poems um
just to touch on a fifa's poem i think
that it's a testament to this natural
compassion and good hardness that we as
humans have
and can feel and that is such a uniting
force that allows us to stand up against
like different oppressive
things around us regardless of how we
identify
or what nationalities we may have
and i would just like to say like may
kashmir and all countries who are
undergoing someone's struggles be
free from these limited and binding
forces
and be able and have its citizens be
able to live freely and happily
um so i would like to read
two uh two poems my first poem called
um is 2009 and this was a poem that was
inspired by
my first
experience in like a summer camp that
opened up my
eyes to a whole bunch of different
things
whether it be friendship or creativity i
just found it to be one of
the
most inspiring times in my life
so
uh 2009
9 30 to 11 a.m art house
i miss the simplicity of these times the
abundance of laughter
endless smiles and sunshine
the small shed filled to the brim with
paint and clay
tables and kilns scattered
drinking gallons of juice every morning
as motivation to finish our pottery
music from the radio numbing our
thoughts the camaraderie our special
glue
11am to 12 30 franklin's field
when i smash the dodgeball on your face
during all sports
we always take ourselves far too
seriously and dumb coolers of water onto
the losing team jumping to heights we
didn't know existed
1 30 to 3 p.m computer lab
how about a break from the outdoors
something a little more tame just
kidding
nerdy kids thirsting for a pulitzer
writing our own stories and reports
weekly editions of our own little fun
3 p.m to 4 30 p.m room 416
always saving the best for last right
how could i forget about you
surrounded by teenage testosterone the
only girl for three weeks
building robots that come to life
soldering friendship through metal and
care
august 11th august 11th my heart
not a goodbye but uh see you later
i never felt yearning like that before
marking my calendar for the next year
praying for a quick trip around the sun
and
the next poem that i would like to share
is called
live thoughts as i'm skydiving um and
this poem
is
kind of uh
kind of like a streamline of my direct
thoughts uh the very first time i went
skydiving which was um very funnily left
in switzerland where indrone is right
now so i'm very slightly jealous
um
well i've thought that some skydiving
i love the adrenaline the thrill of
adventure coursing inside
scared out of my mind
i'm all over the place
impulsive decisions are my strong advice
up until i'm actually out of my comfort
zone
arms failing deeply sinking the wind
whipping in my face
the lakes beneath me
blue
so beautifully different from the skies
i never imagined i'd find it so ugly
from up here
i hate this while i'm having the time of
my life
talk about a panorama but did i just
swallow a fly
time seems more meaningful up here
i feel like i'm looking at a board game
everything a tenth of its size we get
closer
the distance between us smaller but my
fear
more real
what looks so tiny now giant
daunting
i push my legs out ready to come back
and
it's the ass landing that grounds me
again
and i'm thankful to the sky
i see things differently now
thank you
thank you so much
i
before
we go to our next point i just want to
read you a few comments people have
sent in about this book
nahan shujat writes
a timeless collection that tells the
story of all i find myself reading our
ancestors did not breathe this hair
any time i want to feel connected with
my ancestors
and myself
survived webb
who is the resident scholar the islamic
center at nyu writes through a rich
journey of thought and ideas each poet
captures highly personal imagery that
none of us can afford to ignore
i strongly encourage the reading and
study of this vital work
and professor sana ayer who wrote
indians in kenya the politics of
diaspora adds a moving collection
from a new generation of young muslim
women who bring not only a fresh voice
to these issues but a poignancy that is
both lyrical
and urgent
this is a community enterprise and the
next point besides being
an excellent lyricist and
yes uh
is also a speaker of spanish and the
book designer for beltway jorge reiter
sandoval
she served as a bridge on some of the
the zoom conversations as as the as the
design was being developed
so thank you for that
i say angela given leah was born in
austin
into a family with a turkish father
a venezuelan mother and three older
brothers
growing up in texas france and various
parts of upstate new york i see as
always
use reading and writing for connection
reflection and relaxation
as she moved from place to place
she sees poetry in particular as a form
of writing that can surpass the bounds
of what words are expected to be
in turn connecting her with others icy
got her bachelor's degree in biological
engineering with a minor in creative
writing from mit
and is currently a master's student in
the bio mechatronics group at the mit
media lab
through her work i see aims to emphasize
empathize
educate and inspire
the way that the works of others have
always standing for her
please go ahead i see
you thank you so much and drawn for that
lovely introduction
and um before i go on and talk a little
say two of my own poems i wanted to
comment a little bit on alina's
and i just wanted to say that i love how
2009 really takes me back to childhood
summers
and i also love how life got
life thoughts while i'm skydiving
always reminds me to have perspective
it also gives me a little bit of a laugh
so that's that's always great as well
so the first poem that i'm going to read
from the collection
is called a sampling of my favorite
lullaby
just gonna jump right in
a sampling of my favorite lullaby
knowing my fatiha and abc's tracing them
in a book you drew for me
nos pojitos di sen
looking for you through the cafeteria
doors to plant a lipstick kiss on the
cheek
i would not wipe away
p-o-p-o-p-o
scooting my way into the uprooted
sidewalk you helped me limp home
quando tienen
missing almost every half day saturday
because you let us
struggling with an essay in fourth grade
he said right right right and figure out
the rest later
even with yours needing help limping to
the bathroom you took me a soccer
lesta la comida
getting me a present whenever it was
someone else's birthday
a cucaradi
cooking my friends turkey meals my
favorite part the way you made the
stuffing with a spinach and strawberries
changing the emphasis from me to yours
and i'm not there to lift your load
hasta lotro
i'm sorry
so for this poem the parts that i sang
uh and were in spanish are actually from
uh this po a chilean poet it's ismail
paraguess um and it's from a book that
was first published in 1907 um called
poesias infantiles which is basically
just a uh
like children's nursery rhymes and but
the way that i knew it growing up was my
mom would often sing it to me as a
lullaby and it's one of the first
lullabies i remember ever hearing
uh the second poem i want to share
is uh called dear my favorite memories
and maybe those from mit maybe some
things will uh
you'll relate to a little bit
dear my favorite memories
jumping onto the car roof because you
are not walking home in the cold from
this restaurant where i only had
goldfish and for some reason it's a
problem that i supposedly never finish
my food in fact it's funny to you say i
care about your day and i do and i'm
touched that it touches you see me from
across the room and you scoot your way
over and i haven't a clue about this lab
report we put our sweaters on backwards
so at least we're warming up this room
with book clubs and 320 struggles that
you got me through the night when i just
wanted this presentation prep to end i'm
singing down the hallways where you find
me always
the warmth you feel radiating from me
really comes from all of you don't you
see formulation and catalyzation that
night across the charles you talked
about building while flying i didn't
know you appreciated the first time we
met i thought you thought i was annoying
essays were in while making it bus you
kept me company
reminiscing memories do mean so much to
me i don't know how to process so you
put on headphones over your earbuds as
you backed out of the room i'm laughing
at the singular mango party of four
isn't it obvious that i too and muslim
like you see me as a mentor i'm just
lucky getting to love all of you
thank you
thank you so much
you know i wish we could we could hear
more than two poems from each of you i
mean i'm it's a very touching uh thing
you know uh
this this evening and uh thank you for
for sharing your work i'm
my next boy
maisha
manawara promise um
you know
has also written some very strong poems
on this book i
but you get struck by her poem rice i
don't know she's going to be reading
that but
it's just
each of these poems you know there's a
can be read on on different levels
you read this
it's testament
it's lyrical
inquiry from the from the heart but
it can also be read as a social
statement a political
reading of the world and uh
i think that's one of the the treasures
that you'll discover when you read these
poems
was born in dhaka bangladesh
and has moved back and forth between
bangladesh and united states
throughout her life
maisha used to write poetry as a child
growing up in new york city
but rediscovered it in college while
taking classes
from her writing minor
aside from poetry maisha enjoys all
things creative from baking to
crocheting to writing fiction
she oh dear i hope you we don't lose her
to fiction one day
i think you can write both fiction and
poetry
she has won awards for her short stories
and hopes to continue writing alongside
working in research and education
maisha graduated from mit with a
bachelor's degree in biological
engineering she is currently pursuing
her phd in biological sciences at yale
university go ahead marsha
thank you so much for that uh
introduction and john um
yeah and aisha your last poem um i have
to say is one of my favorites in the
whole entire book and it's just so many
beautiful memories strung together into
single poem and i feel like all of us um
have a version of this poem based on our
own experiences somewhere inside our
hearts so thank you for that
i'm also going to read two poems today
and the first one is called since the
day i arrived and it's about the first
day i moved into mit as a
freshman a sunny new day
a paint splash sky
a trunk pack full
of four-year supply
a scarf just as blue covers my face as i
cry
i've mourned the day i would leave
since the day i arrived
a twin stacked building
a bright green lawn
a never-ending hallway
a september song
a promise of growth in the four years to
come
when the car pulls away it leaves me
somewhere
i finally belong
my second poem um is called a thousand
places
um and i've moved
a lot in my life and this is just a note
to all the different places i've called
home
yellow earth between my toes chasing
chickens through the yard
the slip on mosaic tile before the crash
and the permanent scar
a strip of airplane carpet miles above
the gleaming sea
gritty granus of the schoolyard scraping
raw against my knee
polished floor of marble tile like ice
in the winter chill
dorm room carpet brown and warm
with the history undistilled
treading through pearlescent snow and
through monsoon flooded streets
i've walked a thousand places
and found home beneath my feet
thank you so much
thank you
we now will hear from
maryam
emman dugar
maryam was born in singapore and has
lived in dubai and massachusetts
moving every few years
she describes the closest things to
home
as the intangible bridge she and her
siblings occupy between the very
different countries cultures and
families of her u.s american mother and
pakistani father
maryam has loved writing since
elementary school
creating fictional worlds and characters
on the back of her notebooks
however she started writing poetry
during her time as a biology major
an urban planning minor at mit
poetry is now deeply connected to
self-care and spirituality for barium
while she is training to be a physician
at harvard medical school
and and you know i there are so many
lovely poems here i don't want to
pick anyone i'll just sit back and
listen but i i just want to say
another sort of theme throughout this
book
is it's the choice of language
and
all the languages that we carry with us
and
how we're seen
as we use our languages
go ahead thank you
thank you and john and before i begin i
also just want to say a few words about
maisha's poems um
so i think maisha's super power is being
able to use
maybe three four words to be able to
describe a scene that you would imagine
took maybe
three sentences four sentences
she she really packs the punch and i
think that you know people
as you can see in the comments are
resonating with with your poems maisha
today i'll also be reading two poems um
the first one is called tangerine
lately i've been starting to feel my
soul instead of my body
like that day on the beach with the
rocks and the sunset
footsteps so faint i could almost
levitate
with the horizon speaking into my ear
be content
or when i sat at the dinner table in the
center of the forest
a citrus spread and the smell of durian
between us when he leaned forward and
whispered that he could feel his
ancestors in the air
or when i pass a tiger lily and feel a
touch on my arm
tracing the outline of the last day she
could stand upright
when we walked in the garden and i
painted her toes
a bright orange that decorated her feet
on her deathbed
or when my knees knock against the
strangers and i remember us in the back
of a sedan with a broken ac
sharing secrets for hours in the
delirious globe the desert
giving me inconvertible proof that you
did exist
see i've come to the conclusion that i'm
not quite literal
i am memories transcribed without my
knowledge like the passive rise and fall
of my chest
or the tears that slip from my eyes when
i laugh
in this brilliant orchestra i collect
these moments undeniably alive and
imperfect and sentient
i am congruent with the hearts i've met
before
and those he bids me to meet again
so just a few words about this poem um
hopefully when you when you read our
book you'll see that each chapter we all
give our take on uh on a certain prompt
and and the prompt for this chapter was
on being real and i remember being very
confused what does that even mean and i
think
what
how i interpreted it was
thinking about what
not being real is and what the people
that
i've had in my life that are no longer
physically in front of me
have meant to me and
yeah that is sort of how
that poem came about
and then for my next poem um
it is called
period but the actual punctuation mark
of the period
you woke to a surprise on your bed pure
white sheets stained rusted red they
said it was normal nothing to fear but
the sight of your blood kept feeding the
tears
you cried for what you couldn't know but
felt you grieve the innocence that you'd
once held
you lost a childhood of skirts and
shorts they now controlled your body
parts
the next month your world turned crimson
again coach said wear tampons like other
women
at home you googled what tampon means
then you close the laptop and quit swim
team
your accidents were public with family
and strangers
you'll never forget the whispers and
fingers
you prayed for the pain the others
talked about so that next time you could
catch yourself before spilling out
one month you're ambushed by two visits
you then leave the masjid entirely to
avoid the critics
sometimes your brother would throw a fit
he's mad when you aren't praying and he
is
it would be simple to explain to him why
but the thought makes you feel small
instead you hide
that's girl at school you learn about
the menstrual cycle
you hear them in the back periods make
girls go psycho
as the days pass they always have more
to say
about what you wear and how you pray
who you should touch and for how long
where you should travel and why you're
not strong
to you i say a woman is not a sin you're
a miracle sister you've always been
you bleed and heal as you sprint through
life
your soul purpose i promise is not to be
a good wife
you carry them in your belly and upon
your tongue heavy on your shoulders and
deep inside your lungs
you are unscripted power my dear and we
won't forget it
thank you so much
was born in chennai
india and is called when he places home
across the u.s and in saudi arabia the
united arab emirates and qatar
she completed her bachelor's and
master's studies in computer science at
mit
and is currently pursuing a phd in
robotics
in artificial intelligence at the
university of california in berkeley
she is drawn to poetry for its oral
tradition and grew up hearing her dada
saab recite the works of muhammad iqbal
and jalal ad-din
mohammed ruby in their home
in south india
performing writing and listening to
poetry allows her to connect with god
and understand existence
it is her form of dawah to herself
and the world
of july
thank you and ron i'm the first thank
you
um before i begin and i'd also like to
comment um on miriam's poem uh and
there's so much to say it's a little
time but
for me tangerine it's
you know the the title is so misleading
um you know it's it's um
it's really packed so much it's a breath
of fresh air and so much more and then
no matter how many times i hear the poem
period i feel a mix of anger and
empowerment and i am so grateful that
you touched on such a taboo topic
um and it makes our our collection all
the more powerful
um
and with that i'll start off with my my
first poem
um and it is about my experiences taking
part in interfaith dialogue at mit
known as a deer
which some of you might be familiar with
the group
so it is titled
when in dialogue
a mormon a muslim and a hindu
sat at the corners of a rounded table
chatting away on the weather and
business of the day
they had gathered to discuss truth
as their souls watched behind happy eyes
afraid to speak on their creation and
existence
they spoke of intentions before
conversation
gathering questions they sought to
understand
they were equal partners in search for a
reason
for surely if god willed
god would make them one community
the mormon spoke of her mission abroad
peace found and disconnecting from the
world
the muslim felt a sense of holy envy
he wished he was more vocal about his
faith
the muslim shared stories of
perseverance of the last prophet
raising the importance of giving to
sakat in his faith
he finally felt comfortable stepping
away for zahar salah
the hindu admitted she could be spending
more time in prayer
the hindu believed in many chances at
life
she held respect for her parents above
all else
yet confessed she wasn't always so sure
of certain traditions
the mormon expressed she empathized
though she couldn't always voice it
and so the mormon the muslim and the
hindu discussed ideas and not people
in mutual understanding of their
differences
leaving with what was learned
and not spoken
and now my next poem um is reflecting on
being an immigrant from india and later
becoming a u.s citizen and living with
all the ways in which i am
so it's called a citizenship
you step outside when a gush of spice
hits the air and you and your nose
it's embedded deep within the fabrics of
your jacket
the thai detergent never seems to mask
the smells of homeland you are so
ashamed of
they ask you why you smell like spice
and why your food has so much pepper
vasco de gamba didn't go to india to get
pepper
he went to get the haldi in sambar and
chicken gel frizzy and the zeera and the
butter chicken you have when you think
you've experienced india
you shrug in response
abba told you that you are now an
american
i remember the time i became a citizen
of this country
age 10 two-piece hijab removed for a
passport photo
shame knowing you didn't fight for your
right to dignity
shame knowing your mother and sisters
did the same
you knew in that moment when you and
your two-piece scarf ran through the
isles of costco with your money in her
shiny her mother in her shiny and new
black abaya they stared
and now
you speak in the language of your
colonizers from
1858 it would only be years later
when you were gifted the power of the
pen
to acknowledge the seams in the fabrics
of your jacket
thank you
well there you have it a sampler
just two poems from each
of six points
there are many more in the book
and each one uh very very very
charged
as i mentioned earlier it can be read on
so many
levels
apparently simple lines
with very deep profound like sort of
feelings and thoughts
embedded side
i'm
lost track of time but
if there are any questions from the
audience i think we have
a few minutes we can take a couple of
also for any of the poets
please uh
leave your question in the chat
and uh
please do
let us know if you'd like to
um or if you'd like to ask the question
directly
perhaps
the mics can be
opened
for everyone in the uh in the zoom
a lot of appreciations in the chat
but um for any particular question
here's a chance it won't be the first
opportunity
i trust this this group will be will be
going on the road in a sense
this one does in america with a new
album
or
if not on the road
through the zoo the zoom room um
so i think there's an in-person reading
coming up in may i just found out about
um
as a question for us
could you share the name of the chilean
children's book of poems
yeah it's called poe
i will also send the name of the author
and the
in in the chat now as well
good question
i think there are the
questions
thank you mark for this
great
generation
and thoughts okay
like said former
mit
an mit graduate
poker student at mit so
there's a long learning poetry and
practicing poetry at mit and
and these six boys are
the latest uh
in in the in that line
the latest sports in that line
any other questions for for them
um
if not i just want to say uh
look for beltway editions.com online
or look for
the um
the instagram page for
beltway or for our ancestors to don't
breed this air
um
[Music]
and
and
come and pick up the book uh it'll be
it'll be out soon and soon it'll be
available also in
bookstores and
amazon but
we're waiting for the first copies to be
sent from the printer as we speak thank
you very much everyone
uh
would any of the poets like to say some
closing
remarks or
uh yeah i just wanted to
thank ed um a lot of us our common
thread
was taking your class at mit and just
realizing that this was something we
also like to do in addition to
to all of our other identities and
responsibilities um just
creating the space for this in the first
place and
i know we're all very grateful for all
of your
help and feedback throughout the entire
process
yes
it takes a village and uh
you're a very important part of that
village so thank you thank you for
for encouraging and inspiring these
poets to
to take this path
so it really it's just an amazing thing
it's
we're waiting for the birth of the child
the child is almost here
and uh thank you everyone thank you
welcome
uh and uh let's look forward to the next
reading there the official launch of the
book will be
on i think it's may 7th um
so start to spread that word put that
word in that date in your calendars
um
and
let's meet again soon
thanks
on behalf of all of us
thank